benvenuti ragazzi questo nuovo bisogno
di aprile o se oggi siamo al 165 quindi
ogni cinque episodi come sapete tutti
facciano i livelli speciali che cosa
sono i livelli speciali ci sono dei
livelli che sono stati messi nella hall
of fames dovremo giocare lì tutti prima
o poi l'ex miss piemonte mayem che non
ho idea di che cosa possa essere monte
miami e la madonna un nuovo veicolo
bellissimo va bene presto z
cosa vuol dire che posso usare a nuovo
bellissimo bellissimo
pensavo di poter usare l'ici ragazzi
sarebbe stato ancora più figo
sinceramente però va bene anche il
pulmino giorno a siamo alla svizzera
allora va bene titolo subito kg mai
svizzero ragazzi lasci like anche chi
non lo è la faccia dopo andava funivia
con una mano sola
una mano sola ciò solo quella prendiamo
lo vai a caso ho solo una mano occhio
che questo è diventato una specie di
rock swing non è stata bravura una mano
mi regge al limite se devo essere
sincero attenzione ora non ci arriverò
mai
miley cyrus porca vacca beh dopo sull
aborto no che pirla non avevo capito che
sono stupido nuovo capitale dopo star
fermo porca vacca
se sei caduto e sei morto va bene è la
triste fine della persona che non sapeva
andare in montagna anche la prima volta
che sono andato in montagna mi sono
sentito un po così è se devo essere
sincero prova è fatto benissimo sto
livello non è un caso che sia uno dei
più votati in assoluto
non capisco perché l'ambientazione di
svizzera proprio il resto a posto ci
sono arrivato bike party è un livello
particolare ragazzi però senso e
problemi hai fatto veramente bene
peccato voglio capire dove va a finire
sta roba avrò ok non so se mi conviene
entrare sul nuovo via o se continuare
così sulla piccone via perché alla fine
un picco nel contrario well posso
scegliere di andare anche sullo slittino
quindi ci sono tutte ste vie che posso
scegliere di fare sono quattro finali
diversi va bene allora scegliamo di fare
questa qua
prima vedere ai ha spaccato una gamba ma
ha posto slittino rischio per niente ci
sono sei finali sono sotto il real
adesso un partito non vale basta che ci
sia un finale
nient'altro non so con che criterio con
che fisica rimanga incastrato va bene
guarda la caduta finale è stata perfetta
sembri un delfino fammi vedere gli altri
finali ti prego stavolta ragazzi forse
posso provare ad andare dove stava
andando prima che non sono entrato ho
bellissimo bello perché quando neanche
preoccupare perché teoricamente chiuso
quindi e safe quando dico queste cose mi
esplode il gioco non è aperto e come
esco di qua a ok sono uscito di culo ma
io credo da fai qua ma togliti giunta
orca vacca è un fiore un po strano però
va bene sentiva e cambiamo perché se non
facciamo questo livello un altra volta
pro bello bello mi è piaciuto facciamo a
laboratori uno tedesco a trovare
qualcosa di figo nei laboratori lezioni
cos'è che santo fatto incredibile
l'altro laboratorio con nonno chuck non
so quanto possa essere giorno oddio
emilia è meglio lo ricordate uguale
occhio
vabbè ma con noi non c'è anche non
potevo sorpassato il tuo livello va bene
allora cambiamo charter mettiamo lui
perché non lo sa che infattibile sta
roba purtroppo non mi toccare maria ti
regalo la mia scarpa non me ne faccio
niente della mia testa invece me ne
farei qualcosa però allora 12 è
affacciata sul muro ma fa niente occhio
ha visto e scassato cosa non ci credo e
quindi posso continuare anche senza
posso continuare a emilio aia pezzo di
culo aiuto dai allora sei un pezzo ho
dato una testata a mi escluso il
cervello avevo normale cose che
succedono comunque edificio livello non
è facile c'è però la mi sto impegnando
per riuscire a finirlo cavallo non è
facile per niente anzi andiamo avanti in
avanti comunque non credo sia nascondo
ma il padre uk era ancora meglio
quello perché è bello e di un pochettino
lento a volte prova per fargli fare
proviamoci
perché altre per le mine perché come lei
come le schivava quel padre di uk è
impossibile ci siamo
stavolta ce l'ho fatta più ok emilio
l'ho lasciato indietro chi se ne frega
vamonos che comunque è imposta
è un bel livello però non era un livello
da dire mamma mia
26 milioni di volte la giocata di tura
come se fosse comunque world of mystery
del mondo dei misteri ragazzi è questa
una grafica già paurosa cioè solo così
poi giorno lo vado la ragazza è fatto da
di questo livello
porca vacca di zucca cazzotto era un
albero spero sia simile a limbo sembra
molto simile al in blu 3 3 non ricordo
se l'avevo già giocato in un video non
buttare perché questa roba dei livelli
questa roba ragazzi dei livelli più
belli di epping scaioli gioco ogni
cinque episodi quindi ogni episodio
multiplo di cinque così imparato anche
le tabelline
però è una cosa che sto facendo da
quando ho iniziato a fare è più in siti
dagli ultimi mesi no e quindi non mi
ricordo se c'erano dei livelli del
genere che avevo giocato tempo fa
sicuramente questo fa mi pare di averlo
già giocato ma non ne sono completamente
convinto solo fare queste le questo
ascensore ha bisogno di una chiave per
funzionare va indietro e trova delle
chiavi da questa parte va bene avete le
chiavi a prestarmi eva dico non ci sono
chiavi che faccio clicca sulla roba va
bene apriti schivo cielo cliccare sui
cartelli o chiesta cosa quando l'avevo
capita smantella tutto ho trovato un
telecomando
cioè non è che non è che dici la chiave
il telecomando el'ascensore vabbè però
con cui chiude i video mi stava
schiacciando fortissimo meno male che
ogni sorta di sopra piani sopra clicca
ogni sogni trave per tirarla fuori va
bene a benevento
ok chiave allora prendi chi sta chi è
che tra l'altro sto cancello non ha una
serratura però la buffa ben apriamolo
non si sa come next bella adesso trovo
dei diamanti come mai entrato non so
bene sta roba che si illuminano delle
meduse volanti sono dei cappelli sui
capelli dico che ci siamo ragazzi cosa
devo fare
cos'è è sceso un team o network a vacca
a devo tirarmi indietro
e vabbè lo tira e tira lo
ci devo stare qua fermo e non stai fermo
dai fermo fermo vai abbiamo si chiude in
mamma mia
thank you for plague guarda mysteries
mamma mia ragazzi non è stato male però
che ansia
bene anche oggi ne abbiamo fatti tre
dire che ci può stare a farsi ancora uno
veloce facciamo temporanea caso uno che
non avrei mai cliccato però so come il
gioco quindi vediamo come è stato fatto
tanto quando è più se ha avuto successo
era anche il successo di tenere al
periodo in cui ha avuto successo
temporaneo quindi teoricamente faccio
schifo
teoricamente è conosciuto anche solo per
quello non è tanto bene il fatto che un
buon livello anche se non è male per
niente però diciamo che di norma non
l'avrei mai giocato ma visto che siamo a
fine video vi serio rivelo porto potrei
pensarci avevo giocato il livello forse
non questo ma sempre unite imporranno
una volta è molto figo cercando di porti
ed ecco questo nel gioco non potrebbe
mai succedere ve lo garantisco io però
vabbè è dimenticato la moneta scusa
molto bene bravo vai avanti anzi vai vai
avanti tu io ti sto dietro bravo e anti
varianti ma porca vacca se inutile male
dice bravo bravo
perfetto dico grazie a lui e ai
dimenticato nelle monete prova niente
molto bene a 14 ne ho preso un po di
meno però va bene 15 corri corri dai
porca vacca ci sei mi sta portando lui
al traguardo finale solo che se
incastrato la l'edizione avevo rifaccio
però ottimo il fatto che lui mi possa
portare al traguardo finale melo
ricordare ragazzi il vostro nemico e
rotay vostro miglior alleato in tutte le
cose porco demonio come lei gli haters
allora salta fa il salto decente ok ok
molto bene sapete che ho scoperto
nessuna roba che mi sa che non avevo mai
scoperto sti premuto shift fa i salti
più alti ed i ma l'ho scoperto al
165esimo episodio di happy meals
digiuno se tenete premuto shift con è
difatti un pelo più alti saluta non lo
sapevo poi una mia percezione bomba back
signori questo era il 165 episodi è più
il tempo run
niente male quello di prima tutto tipo
limbo molto figo laboratori faceva
schifo ma il primo e mount mayen è
veramente figo però va beh per adesso
concludiamo qua 4 stavolta li o finiti
l'ultima volta neanche uno era però ben
quattro niente male grave di sempre
cento ragazzi iscritti al canale
schiacciante il mi piace la campanellina
primavera giornali nuovi video che
escono che è molto importante e noi ci
vediamo come sempre al prossimo video
bella ragazzi
[Musica]